hey guys this is andrew for
tradingsenses.com i've been working as a
professional trainer for the past six
years in hong kong and right now i'm
doing youtube videos
because guys i want to pass the
knowledge i want to show you how
protraders are actually working
how we do our analysis the different
tools and techniques that we use
so if you want to know about all this
stuff and to know how to make money on
the market
you are in the right place so today i
want to make an analysis on the dxy
let's get into it
[Music]
so guys the dollar index for those who
have watched my previous videos i have
already done
one analysis on this few months ago the
situation has not changed that much guys
i was identifying that we were having a
similar pattern as we used to
have in 2017 that we have this bearish
trend
with forming a wedge pattern and that we
probably going to have some
concentration around this level all
right
this is what is actually happening now
so and then as you could see guys we had
you know a breakout on the upside and
the market just moved higher
dramatically
so here what do we see
on the daily time frame here fake
workout i mean
this is not even a fake breakout this is
not a breakout a breakout is when you
have two consecutive candles
training above your resistance level or
below your support level
so here we have one but the second one
closes below guys so this is not a
breakout
then we go lower lower here same thing
we are higher and then bam we close
lower so we didn't have any breakout
here the breakout happened guys
one candle closes above second candle
above
so this is just purely technically
giving me a bullish
sign so i would maybe wait for re-test
you know around the 90.5 90
90.4 area and probably set up a bullish
trade
but what is telling me guys you know
that i'm not
kind of you know very in line with uh my
own analysis
which is technical here is actually the
fundamental analysis
because as you guys know the economy is
not doing well even if it's recovering
look how much money we are printing so
this is
the fed balance sheet this information
is public you can find it on the
sun louise fed website and it is showing
you guys
how much money they print what we call
fake money it's actually fake before we
print it
after it's printed it goes to the
economy and it's not fake anymore and
look guys
what happened here the crazy move up so
you you probably seen that
already but what is interesting to
notice is that it's keeping increasing
at a very strong pace actually compared
to what we have in 208
this was not going high that much here
it
is going much higher so this is going to
put a very
strong selling pressure on the dollar so
this is telling me guys
actually that this breakout
which is actually happening on the daily
timeframe
might not happen on the weekly time
frame right and we are here talking
about some long-term moves so it makes
sense to be on the weekly time frame
if you don't know which time frame you
should use the answer is i don't know
two
you should use the one that is making
the most sense and you should actually
use
all of them and compare here i have a
breakout on a daily timeframe
i would not feel super comfortable to
take it because of this pressure that is
giving by the fundamentals and the heavy
money printing so i check the weekly
time frame and i can see that we don't
have to break out
so maybe i would wait at the end of the
week which is
friday to see if yes or no we
are having this breakout confirmed so
basically if
the dollar index is closing above
so 90.3 before the end of the week
then i would have a breakout on the
daily and on a weekly
so then i would like rather trust my
technical analysis
than my view based on fundamentals
because my view based on fundamentals
is biased technical analysis is not
biased it's
pure it's giving you signals that you
know
just work if you follow them rigorously
on
the long term so guys that's it for me
for the dx y analysis i hope you guys
enjoyed this video
i hope it helped you to give you some
levels that you can keep in mind to
build up your views
and once again guys the dx1 is a very
good indicator for the equity market all
right
a rush for the dollar means the equity
market might go
lower but be careful i did some videos
on
analyzing the bubble that we might be in
and i noticed that during the dot-com
bubble the dollar was
rising so be very careful with that
but keep an eye on this and stay close
to shore i see you guys